CEO President Trump says he will choose
that new FBI director before the end of
this week the Justice Department
interviewed eight possible replacements
over the weekend including former
Republican Congressman Mike Rogers
Republican senator Senator John Cornyn
and CBS News contributor that's Fran
Townsend she was president george w
bush's homeland security adviser jeffrey
gazes outside FBI headquarters right now
he spoke to former National Intelligence
director James clapper about James Comey
firing Jeff good morning good morning in
our interview director clapper was
pretty blunt in his assessment of commis
firing the bottom line is he didn't like
how it was done and he made those
comments with the White House parade of
candidates to replace Comey on full
display at the Justice Department
Houston FBI director James Comey is
keeping a low profile at his Virginia
home while a steady stream of candidates
to replace him filed in and out of the
Department of Justice for interviews all
weekend President Trump suggested the
search for a new FBI director won't take
long I think the process is going to
include you know they've been vetted
over their lifetime top contenders
include former Congressman Mike Rogers
who was an FBI agent himself and
previously head of the House
Intelligence Committee
he's been endorsed by the FBI agents
Association acting FBI director Andrew
McCabe is not likely to stay in the top
job he is under internal investigation
over whether he should have recused
himself from the probe into Hillary
Clinton's private email server in an
interview with CBS News former Director
of National Intelligence James clapper
was critical of the way the president
fired Comey well I think it was pretty
shabby pretty shabby there are there is
a graceful way to and someone's tenure
on Friday CBS News confirmed Comey had
refused to pledge his loyalty to the
President and a dinner meeting at the
White House in response to reports about
the dinner mr. Trump tweeted James Comey
better hope there are no tapes of our
conversations well I interpreted as a
not-so-subtle threat yeah I don't I did
I don't know if there's a taping system
there or not clapper says the tweet and
other actions by the President as well
as Russian meddling in the election
suggests an erosion of trust in
institutions I worry about our
institutions which I think are under
attack both from external sources and
for that matter internal that statement
was aimed at the president clapper says
he expects Comey to testify on Capitol
Hill he says he will likely talk about
the firing and the dinner with the
president but in an open hearing not
behind closed doors Norah
alright Geoff thank you so much